[Music]
rer thanks for
ordering still steam coming off the cup
tracked the plane online so I've landed
early you don't check bags and IJ justed
for traffic had the coffee poured 90
seconds ago food's been there 3 minutes
appreciated where'd you get
this I'm a pi I can get things
been a minute since Marg been 2 years 7
months 19
days you look
good I look the
same it look good 2 years 7 months 19
days ago so
yeah you look the same you look Road
warn
[Music]
yep c i noticed that every time fuel
went missing from the base it was always
after specific flight whenever c7's
faired Humvees back home to the states I
mean it's a minor detail but in an
investigation Details
Matter I like that I'm going to use it
it's mine is
[Music]
yours
looks like someone took the sign as a
personal challenge green I'm just
warming
[Music]
up you've been car jacked right don't
turn around this won't take
long
wait who are you someone who prefers not
getting
involved you refer to these special
investigators as your team your soldiers
even your friends you not mess with the
special
investigator and now they're all in
[Music]
trouble they were tortured they dumped
him from a helicopter and they're coming
after
us
[Music]
good damn reer we were kids we just
wrote our names in it why'd you got to
hit them so
high I don't hit
soft what are our
directors we prepared we investigate we
put B guys in jail what's he think he's
going to do nothing to do just like the
good old days yeah you on the sidelines
while I do all the
work he's a boss and bosses give
orders but they took a run at us in
broad
daylight they're getting
desperate guys got good instincts guys
got to get
everything surveillance photos don't do
you
[Music]
justice looks like you had a rough night
had
worse
need a new jacket what's wrong with the
one you just bought it has blood on
[Music]
it